react router is commonly used to create
different routes
for pages in react applications this
course will teach you how to use react
router
to create your own routes in react we're
going to learn about react router
and its different concepts such as
creating different routes for different
pages in react also we're gonna learn
how to nest a route of a page under
another page
hooks like use history use params use
locations and use route match
also how to fetch a query string in form
of a variable from the url
so let's get started
[Music]
okay so let's start by creating a new
react app i'm gonna type npx
create react app
and the name of our app which i'm gonna
give react
router tutorial
now what it's gonna do it's gonna go to
npm's website or npm's repository and
gonna take all of the things needed to
create a new react app
and it's gonna put all of those things
into this folder
react router tutorial it's gonna find
all of the dependencies that we need
to create our react app and it's gonna
basically initialize a boilerplate code
for our react app
all right so it has successfully
initialized our new react app now we
need to switch to that folder
what we can do is either we can type cd
and the name of the folder you can
switch this way or what you can do is
you can
open that folder in vs code which in my
case
is this folder and i'm going to select
this folder
so here we go our folder has been opened
in the vs code successfully
so what i'm going to do now is i'm going
to type npm
start so it's going to start our react
app
here's our react app running
successfully so what i'm going to do now
is i'm going to i'm going to go to the
src folder and i'm going to get rid of
those things that we don't need
so this this this and this we're going
to get rid of these four files
and we're gonna remove the places that
they were being used
so over here
and i'm gonna get rid of all of these
styles
inside app.js app.js i'm going to get
rid of this
get rid of logo
and now you'll see that our app
will have nothing to show
let me refresh it yeah there you go
it's an empty page okay so what i'll do
now is i'm going to type
h1 h1
react router
dom tutorial or just react router
tutorial
let's save this and see
yes it has successfully rendered this
over here
so let's create a different component
for header
i'm going to create a new component
called i mean new folder called
components
it's not necessary to create a separate
folder for components but it's a good
practice
i'm going to create a different
component for header.js
and i'm going to type rafce underscore
rafce and press enter
and let's copy the same thing over here
there we go let's first
center align this thing and then we're
going to start with our tutorial
so i'm going to give it a few of the
styles in app.css
i'm going to give it a display flex
and justify content no
sorry i mean to say align
items to center and
flex direction is going to be column
because we want everything to be top
down
uh you know aligned so yeah here we go
it has
it is in the center so yeah i haven't
done this i've imported the header
component
header is not defined let's just import
it manually
here we go it should work fine now
yep here we go it's working fine so now
we are going to install
react router dom so i'm going to open a
new terminal and type
npm i react
router dom
and you know what i'm going to go to
header and get rid of this dev
let's use the react fragments so if you
don't know what react fragment is you
can watch
my previous video on 18 code practices
in react it's going to help you a lot
2 000 years later
all right so finally our react router
dom has installed successfully
so i'm going to go to my app.js
component
and to use our react router dom what
we'll need to do is we're gonna have to
cover this whole react app in something
called
browser router browser router which
comes from
react router dom so you can see it has
auto imported
so i'm gonna wrap whole of my app in
this
all right here we go let's close this
terminal
i think i'm gonna have to restart my
application so let me just do that
quickly
all right it's fine now so what we g
what are we going to do next is we're
going to create
different different routes for different
different pages that we're going to work
with
so let's create a route for home page
about page
and profile page yeah so i'm gonna type
route
and press enter and you can see route
has auto imported from vs code
i mean from uh react.vs code has auto
imported it
so i'm gonna give it a path
uh this is going to be a home page so
it's going to be this
and we have to give it a component which
we'll create
in a second so let's duplicate these
paths
another one will be for about
and the third one will be for profile so
let's create these pages first
i'm going to create a new folder with
the name of pages
home.js
i'm going to click on the file called
about.js
and the third file will be profile dot
js
let's let me quickly write some code
inside of this
let me type home page i'm going to
remove these divs and
add h1 yeah that's better same thing
with the about page
about page
and the profile page
all right cool profile page yeah all
right cool so we have created all of our
three routes now let's test these routes
if these are working or not
so let me save my app real quick
okay there's an error what's the error
okay we haven't given the components
obviously
so let's just give this home
oh sorry my bad we have to import all of
these components first so
import home from
slash home and i'm gonna do for about
and profile as well so about
and profile
let me just about and
profile here we go so we have created
three routes this is how you create
routes in react by using react order dom
so you can see it's
currently in the root folder i mean in
the root path so it's giving us home
page
let's go to the about page about
there we go it's giving us about but you
can see the home page is also appearing
here and about page is also appearing
here
why is that happening because uh you can
see
it it has about page as well and this
root as well
in this in its path it has root as well
so what we can do is we can type
exact
so it's going to go exactly to this path
and not nowhere else
so if you type about it's going to click
open about page
and if you type profile
it's going to go to what
okay i have made this mistake
yeah now it's going to work fine if i go
to profile page
it's going to open the profile page
another thing which you can do apart
from exact is you can use something
called switch
so if i type switch over here
and i'm going to take all of these three
inside of the switch
and i've imported the switch from react
router dom
so is what switch does is when you go to
a particular path let me remove this
exact from here
so it's gonna find uh whatever it finds
first is gonna
stop there for example it has written a
slash profile so it has found the slash
path first
it has matched this path slash with this
so it is found the home page is gonna
render
if we use switch but if we type exact
then we're not gonna have the same
problem now
you can see it's rendering the profile
now let me type about
alright here we go about page all right
one more thing so
uh we don't need to manually type this
in the url so what can we do to go to
another page
in the our traditional web development
in the html we use something called a
tag
to go to a different page so we can use
that over here as well
but it has a disadvantage what
disadvantage is
there when we click on this a tag it's
going to refresh our page let me
demonstrate that thing
so i'm going to go to our header i'm
going to create
a navigation menu for our app
let me create an unordered list over
here
i'm going to create few list items and
have an a tag inside of it
with href of about no
first is gonna be the home page so let's
type slash over here and give it a name
of home
all right so i'm gonna duplicate these
multiple times
and gonna give this about
about same thing here profile and
profile
let's save this
and currently looks a bit ugly so i'm
gonna give it a little bit of styling
so let's go to our app.css
and i'm gonna add some styling to it let
me give this a class name first i'm
gonna give this a class
name of now
yeah let's give it some styles
so i'm gonna type list style type is
gonna be none so that
it doesn't displace the bullet
and i'm gonna type width
to be 500 pixels
so i'm going to type display flex
and justify content
to be spaced evenly so it spreads around
evenly
now you'll see yep it has spread around
evenly now let's click on one of these
links
if i'm gonna click on home you can see
the page has refreshed over here
if i click on profile again the page has
refreshed we've reached the destination
but the page has refreshed
we don't want the page to be refreshed
we don't want our components to be
re-rendered
so what are we going to do now so
instead of this a tag
what i'm going to do is i will use
something called link
which is provided to us by react router
dom let's click on this link
and you can see it has auto imported so
over here as well link
and lastly
yeah but we can't use href with the link
we need to use something called two
this is the prop that it takes so let's
save it all right
our app has reloaded and let's click on
about
now you can see the page has not
refreshed if i click on home
again so you see this is the power of
react router dom it doesn't refresh your
page
and it takes you to another page in a
blink of an eye
all right cool so let's discuss some
more features of this
library so let's say if i want a
default route for our app what i mean by
that is let me give a base name over
here
if i give the base name as a tutorial
and save this now you see if i click on
home page
it's going to take us to the slash
tutorial if i click on about
it's going to take a slash tutorial
about so this is how you can define
a base name for this by typing base name
equals whatever the name that you need
to use
if i click on profile it's going to take
a slash tutorial profile
so this is a really powerful feature
let's check out another feature of the
browser router
i'm going to remove this and let's say
for some reason you need to use the
refresh feature
so currently it's not refreshing our
page
when i'm taking it to another route so
if i type force
refresh over here then you'll see what
it does
if i'm going to go to about you can see
the page is refreshing now
it's providing the force refresh forcely
our app to re-render everything
so you can use force refresh for that
which i don't think anyone needs to use
also if you want to confirm every time a
user goes to another route for example
if i click on about
you need to confirm it by some prompt or
by some displaying some model
what you can use is called get user
confirmation
you can type get user confirmation and
then inside of this you can write a
custom message to be displaced whenever
the root changes
so i'm going to write a function inside
of it by typing message
oops message and it's going to take a
call back
this is going to be an arrow function so
callback is going to take
window dot
confirm and you can pass whatever
component that you need to pass inside
of it let's say if you create a prompt
you can pass inside a prompt inside of
it or a model
but i don't think this is uh used that
much as well so this is one of the
features
that you can use in react auto dom so
let's remove this
yeah all right let's move forward first
of all i what i want to do is
uh the let's remove these styles from
the links
i don't want this style so i'm gonna go
to app.css
and let's remove the styles by typing a
removing text and decoration
and color will be inherited
yeah fine see our pages are not that big
right now
if you go to home page or if you go to
profile page it's uh
it's uh height is not that big right now
but let's say your your page is so big
that you need to scroll down
so whenever you uh change your route
what's gonna happen it's gonna
continue the other page from the same
position if so what you want to do in
that case
whenever you go to a different component
you can type like this
let me just go over here to home page
and you i can what i can do is i can use
use effect
and inside of use effect i can type
window dot scroll
to zero comma zero so what it's going to
do it's gonna continue the other page
from the top
and not the previous position that page
was
when you were in the other component so
this is helpful
okay so next important thing is if when
we type to some other
route that doesn't exist right now let
me say
anything like something and enter you
can see there's nothing being displayed
over here
we want something to display over here
like zero four error
page not found something like that so
how can we display that over here
let me create a new page for that i'm
gonna new
i'm gonna create a new page called not
found
dot js all right
let's initialize this page r a f c e
press enter and i'm going to give it an
h1
of oops 404
not found let's save this
now how can we uh how can we use this
now we need to go over here
let me close this yeah we need to go
over here we need to create another
route
we've created another route in
this case we're not going to give it any
of the path such as about or profile or
anything
we're just gonna give it a component
not found
i'm gonna manually import it here we go
we've imported our not found page and
here we go
the message is displayed successfully if
i go to somewhere else
it's gonna still display this message if
i go to a relevant page
like home about a profile it's not gonna
display any of the message
all right so let's move to the next
thing which is taking parameters from
the url
so let's say if i want a page like
something called
post and we want some random post
so we want this random id to be
accessed by us so what can we do over
here so currently it's going to show 404
not found
so let's create a new page for our post
yes so what we want to do is want we
want to fetch
this particular id so let me type id
is and we're going gonna display the
particular id
i'm gonna give it h2 over here
currently it's not gonna display
anything if i go to post
okay we haven't created the route
obviously we need to go to app.js and
create another route
here we go we have created this path
successfully now you can see
it's showing us id is equals which we
can't do anything if we
just slash type anything it's gonna no
it's not gonna display anything
so what we need to do now we're gonna do
is slash
id so now it's gonna take a random id
from us so if i go
to post now it's gonna display not found
because
that page doesn't work needs to have an
id to display so let's go back to our
page
and now we're gonna use our first hook
which is called
use params or we can use a match as well
let me just display uh
let me just demonstrate it with the
match first so we're going to go over
here
destructure the match from here
and now what we're going to do is we're
gonna
go over here and type match dot params
and what what was the name of the param
it was id
let's save this and let's check this out
now
here we go if i give this uh
let me type random over here and press
enter you can see
the id is generated and it's displayed
over here
i mean it's not generated we have
provided it but it's displayed over here
yeah so what's the other way to do this
the other way to do this is using
use params hook which is provided to us
by react
router dom so i'm going to click over
here and you can see it has auto
imported from react.arm
now we don't need this i'm going to get
rid of this
i'm going to use use params let's first
log this use params let's see what do we
get inside of this
i'm going to remove this now so it
doesn't give error all right let's log
this use params
and inspect this we get an object
and this object has something called id
inside of it
which is the id that we have passed over
here let me type
something and press there we go it has
given us another
object with id of something so
now we're going to use this use params
i'm going to type const id
equals use params and we're going to
destructure this id inside of the use
params
so we have taken out this id and we can
just use this id over here now
let's save this and let's check here we
go
something let me give it a random number
and here's our idea displayed
successfully so this is how you can
fetch the id from the
url now let's say we need to use a we
don't want to
change our route but we still need to
use
the variables from the url for example
if i type question mark
and i let's say i type name equals
push let's say we want this name
this name how can we fetch this from the
url
is there any other way so we're going to
use our second hook
called use location use
location and it's also provided to us by
react router dom so we're going to type
use location over here let me just
log this use location first and check
what do we get inside of this
let's go to inspect we get an object
so what does this object has it has a
path name
and it has a search with the value of
name equals push let me type something
else
first equals push
and we can type and last
equals agarwal which is my name so yeah
let's see now the value of search has
changed
to first equals push and last equal
aggregate now how do we fetch these
first
and last variables from this search uh
you know variable
search object so
what i'm going to do now so we're gonna
use an
inbuilt api from the browser called url
search params
so i'm gonna select it and i'm gonna
type url
search params and i'm gonna create an
object out of it
so i'm going to type new url search
params
and what do we want inside of this use
location we want this search
so let's type search all right let's
take it in some variable let me type
const
query equals new url search params
here we go so how do we take out the
stuff from this query
so let me just go over here and
h2 and we need to use the first and the
last
so let's first extract the first one
so query dot
get and in the bracket we need to you uh
we need to write the variable that we
need to fetch from the url
so i'm going to type first and save this
let's see what happens okay here we go
we get the push from here
from the first and let's fetch the last
as well
last
here we go so we can type n number of
queries inside of this url and we can
fetch them by using
this method use locations hook
so that's pretty cool now let's see
let's suppose you have a login feature
in your app
and you want user to access the profile
only if
that user logs in into your app so how
how are we gonna modify
our react router dom according to that
let's find out
we're gonna go to app.js and we're gonna
create a new state
let's say
login let me import the use state
from react here we go so
by default login will be false login
will have false value because we are not
logged in now and
let me just create a button over here to
log in
oh but uh i'm not able to type
there we go over here
let me just take this div and
put it over here so that everything is
centered yes it's centered
so what i want is when i uh tap on this
login we're going to simulate a login
feature by making this login as true and
it's going to display log out then
so on click
what it should do it should set
login as the opposite value
so if it's true it's going to be false
if it's false it's going to be true
also what i'll display over here is
if login is true if
which means if user has successfully
logged in then it should display whoa
whoa what's happening yeah
then it should display log out
otherwise it should display login
let's save this and let's see if it's
working or not
okay it's working fine so what we want
to do over here
if our user is not logged in he's not
gonna be able to access the profile page
and he's gonna be redirected to the home
page
so how can we achieve that we're gonna
use something called
redirect from react outer dom
so let's remove this component from here
how i'm going to do this is here we're
going to make the
the child component of this route
let's check this over here if login
is true if login is true then it's going
to be able to access the profile page
so profile otherwise it's going to be
redirected
so redirect
where will it be redirected to home page
here we go all right let's try
clicking on our profile page let me go
to about page and let's click on profile
page
you can see we have been redirected to
home page we can't access the profile
page now
but the moment we press login and let's
go to profile page now
now we're able to access the profile
page so it has become a protected route
for our app
if i'm inside of this profile page and
if i press log out let's see what
happens
it's going to redirect us back to the
home page now there's another way of
doing this
let me show you we can use something
called use history
use history hook so let me just type
this over here i'm going to remove all
of this redirect
stuff i'm going to make it a normal
route now
it's working normally now without login
all right
so i'm gonna what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna send the login as
a parameter inside of this
so i've sent the login as a params
go to profile and destructure the login
out of here
here we go and let's create a use effect
so use effect runs whenever our app is
initialized first time
so i'm gonna take the history out of the
use history hook
so let's type use history
and i'm gonna assign it to const
history variable
all right it has auto imported from
react auto dom what happened okay we
haven't
imported the use effect
here we go all right so what do we need
to type inside of the use effect
we need to check if the user is logged
in
or if the user is not logged in what are
we going to do if he is not logged in
then we will use history dot
push it's gonna push this path to our
url
so it's gonna push to the slash page
which is our home page so let's try this
out
i'm at the home page let's go to profile
page i'm not able to access the profile
page now
let's login and let's go to profile page
here we go we're successfully in the
profile page and let's log out now
whoa what happened i think i have missed
some
[Music]
yeah okay so if we want it to run
whenever the login variable changes
so i'm going to provide login over here
and history
we're going to provide these two
dependencies inside of the used effect
whenever these two dependencies are
going to change it's going to fire off
this function
let's try again we're going to go to
profile it's not going there
i'm going to type i'm going to click on
login what am i
saying today okay so let's go to profile
now here we go we're able to access the
profile page let's
log out here we go we're back at the
home page
if we want to go to about page about
let's say if the user is not logged in
he's going to go to about page if i
click on profile
see it redirects us to about page but if
you are login we can go to profile page
so i hope you all understood
you know this feature of react or dom
let's move to the next feature
so let's discuss how can we create a
nested route inside of a particular page
for example if inside of the profile
page i want to create two routes
with the name of let's say view profile
and edit profile
and i don't want those two routes to
affect our whole react router system
we only want them to work inside of this
profile page so let's create
uh two new routes over here i'm gonna
remove this let me just put it inside of
this
round bases and i'm gonna provide react
fragments to these
all right let's move this
yeah so i'm going to create a nav bar
inside of a profile page
i'm going to create a link tag over here
and let's say view
and the other link tag is going to have
edit edit profile let's see
also we haven't created these view
profile and edit profile components yet
so we also have to create those
view profile there we go we need to
provide it a two
it's gonna go to um
all right so first of all before doing
all of this let's create a route and the
component first so that we have these
errors out of the way
so i'm going to go below this and as
usual we're going to create a switch
whoops switch let's see if it has auto
imported or not yes it has
all right we need to create two routes
route one will have path of
slash view profile
and it has it's gonna have some
component which i'm going to create next
and the other one will be the edit
profile
edit profile yeah let's create those two
components first
view profile.js
okay i made a spelling mistake
viewprofile.js what the heck
p-r-o-f-i-l-e
yes
edit profile dot oops
dot js yeah
let's create this r a f c e
and i'm gonna give it a h2
and view profile page
okay this component has been created and
same with edit profile page
edit profile page giving this h2 as well
yeah fine let's move on to the next
thing
now we're going to go back to our
profile page and over here
we're going to go and give it a 2.
to slash edit profile
and this one to the
view profile all right let's see if it
works or not
route is not defined obviously route and
links are not defined yet so i'm going
to auto import it from the vs code
with the help of vs code here here we go
all of these are important now
right let's see what's the error right
over here link is not defined
link is defined you can see link is
defined over here let's me let me
refresh this
yeah it's working fine let's go to the
profile
okay we have to log in first and let's
go to profile okay we have view profile
and edit profile over here
but it's not working now but why is it
not working now we
because we have already created our
routes over here
so what do we need to do so what do we
need to use
now is we're gonna use something
called use route match hook use
route match so this is the hook that
we're gonna
use to help us you know move our nest
the components inside of other component
so let me type const
and i'm gonna take out something called
path and something called url from
inside
of this thing so let's see how can we
use this path and url
first of all we want to go to we don't
want to go to view profile because it's
taking us to slash edit profile or slash
view profile
we want to go for example if you are at
the profile we want to take the current
url and then
append the view profile after it
so what i'm going to type over here
first of all i'm going to remove this
standard string tags and i'm going to
use backticks
oops
like that okay so now we need to provide
a variable inside of it
which will be url yup now it's going to
work fine
and the same over here
url and i'm going to remove the string
and give it a backtick
just like that so this is how it's going
to work
and over here as well okay we haven't
given it the component
prop so it's going to be view
view profile so it's not auto importing
let me just
import it over here
view profile from
you have to go one step back and inside
the components and view profile
same with the edit profile as well
edit profile it should work now
let me give it a component
component of edit
profile yep so here we go we have
created
our two routes over here so what do we
need to do now
we need to provide it the path variable
because it's gonna know
that the current url that we are in the
current pass that we are in we only need
to append
this particular you uh you know url to
that
url i mean path to that url or the route
to that url
so i'm gonna type path over here
similarly
path over here just like that you know
the drill
i'm gonna do this create it
a back tick
over here as well now everything should
work fine let's try it out
if i click on view profile it's going to
take us to view profile page
you can see slash profile slash view
profile and if i click on edit profile
it's going to take us to edit profile
page
and all of the other routes are working
absolutely fine
there we go if i click on logout it's
going to take us to the home page
so thank you all for watching this react
router dom tutorial i hope you all
understood what are the concept that i
explained to you in this video if you
have any confusion you can comment down
below
to ask me i'll reply to you as soon as
possible